qu'est-ce qu'il se passe quand une
baleine meurt les cadavres de baleines
font vivre les océans alors mort le
corps des baleines se remplit de gaz
c'est pour ça que les choses sur un
rivage elles peuvent exploser sous la
pression mais dans l'océan ça les fait
flotter elles sont déborées par des
requins ou des oiseaux puis au bout de
quelques jours tombe au fond de l'océan
là ce sont les crustacés et les animaux
nécrophages qui prennent le relais il
dévorent jusqu'à 60 kg de chair par jour
mais une baleine bleue pèse plus de 100
tonnes ça représente plusieurs années de
nourriture à la fin il ne reste plus que
les eaux mais c'est pas fini les
escargots et les crevettes ronge le
reste les vers et les bactéries
décomposent les os ça devient un
écosystème à part entière des milliers
d'êtres vivants s'agglutinent autour du
cadavre se nourrissent directement
dessus ou mange les autres espèces
pendant 50 ans vivant ses animaux sont
fantastiques mais même après leur mort